hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the Thursday afternoon
just before Friday Monday morning
podcast and I just checking it on you
what's going on whoa whoa Jesus the
levels levels what happened you know one
of these days I'm actually going to have
like a little podcast room I mean they
have one of those y'all thinks comedy
studios I just never get over there I
never get over there cuz I'm a working
stiff I go to work every day I'm gonna
jump up in 20 years and I'll tell you
right now I didn't miss it oh I didn't
miss getting in the [__] car bum buh
buh buh doo doo doo doo right I don't
think I'll ever get over how [__]
awful the drivers are out here I just
their complete lack of sense of where
their [__] car is if one more [__]
in front of me is going to make a left
and they're just sitting right in the
middle of the link get over to the
[__] left so everyone around you can
go around you I know you've been the guy
trying to get around the person did you
learn nothing obviously you didn't
obviously it didn't I try I play like a
little game like how long can I go
before I lose my [__] like I could
literally just make a great youtube show
if I just put a I don't know about great
but it'd be interesting if I just put a
GoPro up on the inside of my [__]
Prius dashboard and just just maybe you
just call the show how long can you go
right it'd be like every day okay bill
drives from here to here right I might
do this bill drives from here to here
whatever you say the distance and then
you guys can gamble it's like fantasy
football without the [__] football
and you'll be 11 over/under how many
times is he going to snap or whatnot you
know already forget the name of the show
but whatever it could be interesting to
me I don't know if it's interesting to
you and you know what I've been seeing
lately
but I'm actually I like is that
Volkswagen GTI they brought the thing
back and every time I peek in creepily
into the [__] cars as I walk by I see
that they still have the stick shift
there's not a lot of those left
that's a great car good bang for the
buck right all frugal freckles yeah god
forbid he buys himself something flashy
I swear to God you think that I lived in
the depression always here like my
parents how [__] frugal their
grandparents well I think it rubbed off
on them and then it's on to me I'll buy
my [__] wife or anything but I won't
buy myself [__] I just won't do it I
always get there I'm going to buy it I'm
going to do it I got what the [__] am I
going to do that I'm going to have it
and then what that what am I going to do
with it then it's just going to be [__]
in there either going to get dust on it
or someone's going to drive into the
[__] side of it what's the point you
know a very wise man once told me you
know what true wealth is walking into a
mall being able to buy anything and then
you don't and he goes and you walk out
and you have the freedom of that lack of
debt and I'll tell you it's [__]
addicting it really is although recently
somebody just gave me a [__] wireless
Baker I was freaking out about the thing
I actually synched up my phone to it I
couldn't believe how great it sounded I
was going to add it into my gym course
until the lovely Nia heard how good it
sounds she's like that should be in the
house we should both use it so I you
know got [__] out of that thing but so
I'm like an [__] I think it might
even told the story on Monday I was
actually texting people telling them you
got to get a wireless speaker this thing
is [__] incredible
and every one of my friends wrote me
back like yeah I kind of bought one of
those like five years ago it was like
dog you know just you know case yeah you
know I just uh figured it out you know
what I'm actually recording so is my
wife still sleeping and it's her
birthday bat out doodle doodle bat
around right so I don't wanna wake her
up which I probably already did so I'm
going to I'm gonna hang on I'm in this
room and I have these are all my old
drum I can't even say DVDs much most of
these are VHS I bought I bought like
every instructional [__] video you
could the classic I got the Tommy
Aldridge rock drums soloing and double
bass workout
I got another one double bass drumming I
don't know who that is I mean play
double bass Kenny Aronoff power workout
number one and two with the workout
booklet I got the Carter Beauford one
that's a DVD I get Steve Gadd up close I
got the funky drummers who have the
David Garibaldi's power of groove
Omar Hakeem let it flow the modern
drummer festival year 2000 this is all
just drum geek [__] I I got [__]
everybody Keith Carlock
Dennis chambers the drum bass udders the
drummer collective 26 and I got Steve
glandt up close on DVD and in session 2
copies of that for some [__] reason
Jesus Christ look at all these [__]
things Modern Drummer what year is that
one 2008 that's not bad John Blackwell
Gregg Bissonette I got them all I got
them all Dave Weckl Victor Wooten Carter
Beauford sure oh I got I got them all
got them all God knows it didn't help
but you know what I bought them all oh I
bought them all by the way so recently I
said to a buddy mine um I was like you
know what I think the best guitar sound
my favorite guitar sound I ever heard on
an ac/dc album was the for those about
to rock album he was like really I never
listened to that [__] thing bah bah
bah bah bah and that was the album that
came out right after the back and black
album which sold you know like [__]
90 zillion copies so that you there's no
way to go after that right there's no
[__] way to go after that so no
matter what you come up with people are
going to say it's a flop but I [__]
love that album and it just so happened
Dean Del Ray from Jesus I just spaced on
the name of his [__] podcast for those
about the talk no let there be talk it
was one of the ac/dc albums
he he sent me this great article on the
making of the back in black album and I
was so crazy to me because I was old
enough when that came out like I
remember when back and black came out I
was 12 years old and then dirty deeds
came out which was actually a Bon Scott
and he was already dead obviously and
then they released that for whatever
[__] reason now looking at it which
is crazy because Bon Scott dies right
after the highway to hell album and
ac/dc gets Brian Johnson and it's
literally like if this guy doesn't make
it they go right back to playing pubs
who knows what the [__] happens the
band's over and they end up having one
of the you know just basically eight
back in black albums sold more copies
than anything probably other than like
Michael Jackson Thriller or Pink Floyd
the wall not the wall the Dark Side of
the Moon whatever Jesus bill get to the
point here so you think the last thing
you would [__] do is after you've
established a new [__] singer is then
put out some old [__] by the last guy
who's now dead till the [__] new guy
has to re-establish himself all over
again I never even thought about that
because I just loved everything that
they did and I remember being confused
of wide back in black the back the guy
on back in black sounded so different on
dirty deeds because there was no [__]
information back then there was no
internet [__] just came out and like oh
another ac/dc em then you'd put it on
you had no [__] idea especially at 12
I didn't know what the [__] was going on
and then for those about the rock came
out after that so this is great article
talking about all of that and how that
was Atlantic Records they thought ac/dc
was a flash in the pan and they thought
the back in black album I don't know how
the [__] you make an album is great
exactly you don't think that they have
anything else left in the tank so they
were like going well but strike while
the iron's hot and they [__] put out
dirty deeds and the band didn't want
them to it had been released I believe
in Australia and then also in
in England under a different [__]
name I forget I used to know all this
[__] when I was super [__] ac/dc nerd
and also I hadn't talked on a cell phone
for twenty years so I had a memory but
then for those about to rock came out I
remember this [__] kid in gym class
going look you wish you show goes both
Ross I was like I am her yet we just
[__] shocks
I remember thinking like ladies I don't
think it sucks I like that album you
know I like the first song and I find I
never bought the album because he told
me that it sucked until years later I
finally just like [__] dis man I'm going
to buy this album and to this day I
still listen to that like when I go
downstairs you know walk right into my
garage with my [__] gym right just so
awesome that's what I play that's what
I've been playing lately and it's
[__] hilarious like I literally when
I go to my gym now which is just like
back in the day when I lived in my
parents house and I just would go down
to the basement and I would play either
Appetite for Destruction the whole
[__] owl nice to play that whole
album lift to it and then I would go
play drums to it or whatever whatever
album I was into I would lift weights to
the entire album and then I would play
drums to it or try to so I'm in the
middle of doing that yeah yesterday it
was [__] you know mentioned a he a
favorite [__] day the only only
[__] exercise you really keep track
of what weight you putting up and I had
a flashback I [__] I was half asleep
you know writing all day and I try to
get to workout in before I go into the
writers room so I don't become a [__]
fat pasty [__] and so I had the forty
fives on either side right I do a set
and then I was going I thought I grabbed
tens right to just do 155 and I wasn't
paying attention and I picked it up off
the bars I thought it was really [__]
heavy and I just brought it down to my
chest I was like yeah I couldn't lift it
back I grabbed 25 so I went up to 185
which you know I mean when you get
that's a lot of weight for me I mean
that's more than what I wish so upset
I got it on my chest it needs the sleep
and I'm going near me and I can't get it
up it took me back to the days when I
was living at home with my parents and
I'd be going mom mom and she'd be going
I'll be down there in a minute
and I'd be down there like with [__]
like you know 185 190 sitting on my [__]
chest trying to get it up 200 pounds was
always like I was always trying to get
up to that but I was just I'm a
middleweight man like seriously if I
wasn't such a [__] booze bag like I
probably should wait like between 160
165 instead of a buck 80 but that last
15 pounds of tony is nothing but scotch
and pizza right so i got this [__]
sitting on my chest and I'm like holy
[__] I don't I didn't have the clips on
it but I didn't want to [__] I didn't
want to dump it off to one side you know
when you do that and then you get
[__] whipped around because I was
worried I was going to fly into the
mirror right so I ended up having to
roll the thing down like back in the day
and there's that brutal part where it
gets right on your [__] hip bones and
then you got to do the little up and
over your junk and before all the weight
rests on your [__] sighs now it's the
worst I hadn't done in so long and the
closer it gets to your kneecaps and then
finally you got to do that [__] thing
with just it just scrapes your knee
bones and then boom hits the floor and
yeah I did that as a 47 soon to be 48
year old man that was my [__]
yesterday morning I love the hole in
this wall isn't that great you know why
I like the hole in the wall and I'm
looking at right now as I can see the
copper [__] pipe that I had put in
there finally going to get this fixed
get this [__] room painted and that's
it then all I need to do is redo the
kitchen and then it's a brand new
[__] house it's the house that it
should have been that it used to be you
know then I'll probably put it on the
market and I'll take it for like a four
thousand dollar loss buy a house people
it's a great investment
I'm such a [__] weirdo even though
I'm going to lose money on this [__]
house I actually I guess if I guess and
I never sell it I won't write what I
like about it
what I did to the house is I actually
this is going to be weird I feel like a
sense of responsibility when you own a
[__] house you know that the next
person should get it and they should be
like you know what appreciate them you
know the last guy you [__] did this
right he kept it nice you know you ever
see an old guy with an old car but he
kept it nice still got a nice and
[__] waxed and all of that [__] and
everybody goes look at that guy that guy
was raised [__] right you know that's
what I'm hoping the next people are
going to think but I know they're not
they're just going to coming in to
[__] blow and [__] hookers and
there's some goddamn kid running around
with a [__] crayon and ruin all this
[__] not even appreciate that I got the
[__] door locks fixed and there's a
little skeleton key and then you can
lock all the doors like it's 1923 again
you know when you're going to have
Charlie Chaplin over for some [__] non
genetically-altered [__] horse meat
burgers or whatever the [__] they used
to eat back then anyways I need to get
glasses by the way I got to do that I
got to get my physical here so I cannot
I told you what the pilot's license
every two years I got it I don't think
I'm going to pass the eye exam and I was
actually thinking about it like I could
probably get away with it you know I
could probably one more time get away
with it it's like though do you want to
be like 1,300 feet off the ground
getting away with something what are we
doing here why don't we try to get a
[__] priority straight you know and
make it [__] happened so I'm gonna go
get some and I know I'm going to look
like a [__] sex offender so it's
already going to be funny to me actually
you know something you know we did a
joke like that was Ari Shaffir so I got
to give him credit even though that's
not even like lifting a joke that's
exactly what I would look like but not
just maybe flashback when he shaved his
head and he was talked about he couldn't
have his glasses on because if you put
him on he looked like a sex offender see
that not right there's well I don't like
watching other people's X because the
[__] just rolls around in your head and
all of a sudden it just puts one in the
chamber
anyway plowing ahead here
did anybody
anybody listen to the Michael Rapaport
podcast I am Rappaport I called in to
his podcast and we talked some sports
and you know he ended up wanting to put
money on Game seven all right got a
steak dinner and I took OKC and he took
the Warriors I forget what the spread
was but I just didn't feel like it was
enough points I didn't feel comfortable
with the bed it was like seven or
something like that I just said you know
what bump it up to eight you bump it up
to eight you give me eight points I'll
take OKC and he goes all right
you know bet and you know what BAM right
there Fred
[__] eight points exactly what the
spread was dude I [__] called it so
we didn't work out what what a what a
push would be like who would win so now
we're we bet the NBA Finals I took the
Cleveland Cavaliers
he took the Golden State Warriors so
it's a can't even say double or nothing
because nobody won the first one so
that's always a great bet you know a
steak dinner it's not going to break the
bank and then you have to go up and even
though it's costing you money you get a
steak out of it right it's not bad when
you say all right let's plow ahead yeah
let's do a little bit of read some
advertising here for this lovely
Thursday afternoon Ruby the receptionist
oh god this would be some [__] robot
like the baseball kid I met baseball kid
the baseball kid at baseballs would you
want to do the baseball kid will pitch
to you and it was literally like the for
the only child everybody always said
it's for the kid with no friends it's no
it's for the kid with no siblings
because even a kid with no siblings I
mean no friends still had still had a
brother or sister be like hey should you
uh
everybody kind of hates me at school
could you uh throw the ball but is there
anything worse than that how mean kids
are to each other it's [__] brutal
but I'll tell you you know what it ends
up producing some great comedians you
know some psychos driven to [__] take
their app to the next level okay show
shot wall
I'm gonna go to the reunion Evers gonna
be I'm sorry we pushed it down nobody
gives a [__] alright we'll be the
receptionist this podcast is brought to
you by no it isn't it's not brought to
you by Ruby receptionist you [__]
entitled [__] start over Ruby the
receptionist Ruby the receptionist is a
virtual receptionist service that means
you forward your existing business phone
number to Ruby's friendly receptionist
in Portland Oregon who answer on your
behalf
Portland okay smart technology shows Oh
God
they'll dress like Edith Wharton smart
technology shows them details about your
business and your callers even before
picking up the phone so they sound like
they're right in your office plus you
can provide detailed call handling
instructions for everyone in your
business as well as your different types
of collars take a message send them to
voicemail or put them through it
yourself
best of all why is my stomach grumbling
best of all I just had a couple of
waffles
best of all Ruby the receptionist Ruby
receptionist care about connecting with
your callers and making their day while
you're making your business look good
customers agree as they repeatedly rate
Ruby's service as five-star on Yelp
can you guys hear that yeah I just put
the mic up to customers there is
grumbling I just had [__] two waffles
and some bacon customers agree as they
repeatedly rate Ruby service as five
stars on Yelp with Ruby receptionist
it's like having a model full-time
employee for a fraction of the cost plus
they're never sick on vacation or out to
lunch get started today and call Ruby
calm slash bar and get free activation
on $95 value that's call Ruby calm / /
you know it's another thing to is you
can't [__] them Eva so you won't ruin
your marriage you know no matter how hot
they sound they're all the way up in
Portland you know who's going to go up
there unless you live in Eugene
tracker smartphone smart choice smart
home technology is made everything's not
losing your stuff - still still makes my
people feel stupid feel wicked stupid
Duke track
makes losing things a thing of the past
tracker is a coin size device that
locates misplaced keys wallets bags
computers Snowden anything in seconds
just pair tracker to your smartphone's
smatphone
attach it to anything and find its
precise location with the tap of a
button it's that easy lose your phone
press the button on tracker and your
phone rings even when it's on silent
isn't that creepy with over 1.5 million
devices tracker has the largest crowd
GPS network in the world so your lost
item and show lost item shows up on a
map even if it's miles away never lose
anything again with tracker listen
listeners to this show get a special
discount offer of 30% off your entire
order go to be spelled th e tracker tra
cker comm and enter the promo code birth
the hardest thing you'll ever have to do
is find their website go to tracker calm
right now and enter the promo code bird
for 30% off your entire order again hi V
tracker comm flash bar promo code Bert
whatever alright
it is not flash burn no bee tracker calm
promo code Bert that's what it is
alright and finally lastly but certainly
not least ly we don't any one of these
advertisers to feel left out that anyone
is more important than the others at
chest at some point someone has to bring
up the rear look at it this way your
batting cleanup Bowl and branch
everybody sounds like a steakhouse but
it isn't as you said to improve yourself
this is there is one simple thing you
can do every day to help you be your
best in every situation and that's
getting a good night's sleep is not the
truth bolon branch delivers the rest you
need wrapped up in their super
comfortable luxury linens and they do it
right there first betting company to be
the first betting company to be
Fairtrade certified which means that
your sheets come from
work of happy hands not from sweatshops
you know something I wish more companies
did this man you know considering
everything I made I'm wearing was
[__] sewn together at 3:00 in the
morning but God knows who in beginning
and beautiful packaging made entirely
from recycled and sustainable material
so in this company they got the head
screwed on straight you know what
everybody's got a weakness I wonder what
they're doing I wonder what it is
probably smoking meth next please
mention that I'm gonna mention it if you
give it to me
all right let's get through this you can
only get their sheets in one place
that's Boleyn branch calm well you know
you're paying for quality and not
department store overhead you're getting
thousand dollar sheets for just a couple
hundred bucks go online to bowl that's B
Oh L L and branch calm like cliff like
tree branch and they'll let you try them
risk-free for 30 nights you can't lay on
them during the day but 30 nights you
got them you don't love them you can
send them back you got nothing to lose
and it gets even better go to Boleyn
branch calm today for 20% off your
entire order sheets towels blankets
duvet covers everything plus free
shipping and all the products come
beautifully packaged in their signature
boxes go to Boleyn branch calm today for
20% off your entire order and use the
promo code BER that's Boleyn branch calm
promo code BER hi Boleyn branch calm
promo code burr alright my only one who
kind of looked at Ruby the receptionist
say you know just the way they wore that
and now you don't you know for a
fraction of the cost you can under pay
these [__] people you know I like a
[__] receptionist and you know I
might be old school I might be sexiest
sexiest exit sexist what I'm trying to
say I I like the reception the Horry er
the better time they get the job done
nothing better when you walk in right
and it was some [__] you know chick
walk it around with [__] fuck-me
pumps on you know she looks good and all
these goddamn feminists out there that
sit there and they flip out and they act
like every [__] beautiful woman out
there would be a chemist if it wasn't
for men like
me you know some of them they're putting
their best foot forward Jesus Christ
what do you think we have remote
controls for because no one wants to get
up off the couch god damn it if a woman
is born beautiful and all she's got to
do is walk around with her ass jacked up
and a Titch jiggling around a [__]
office and next thing you know she's got
a beautiful home to go home to right
because some rich guy goes in there
going you know what I'd like to stick my
billionaire dick between those tits and
what's wrong with that and then
meanwhile so [__] you know have her
leprechaun jerk-off like me can come in
and I got some to look-look at while I'm
waiting for the [__] doctor to
finally come and figure out what's wrong
with my spinal cord what is wrong with
that what is wrong with that you homely
[__] haters of beautiful women god
bless them god bless them for just
showing up and looking good you know
giving you something to rub one out too
you know everything serves a purpose in
life like right now you some broad you
listening to me I'm probably motivating
you to go write some paper maybe in
Portland you know we all serve a [__]
purpose can't we just let the [__] be
[__] you know there's a reason the
word exists all right and I you know I
guess because men are running [__] but
sometimes there's fewer options but give
me a [__] break
you know to me it would be great if
everything was like even you know what I
mean everything was just fair and the
best got the [__] job right but
that's never going to happen because
we're human beings and that includes
those feminists who don't want it equal
they just want it better for them right
that's why they're only talking about
women they're not talking about the poor
kids that sew together their bed sheets
unless they go to Boleyn branch oh that
little callback to the advertising all
right let's just say it was free not
free let's just say everything was
[__] even are you really going to
tell me that they wouldn't still be that
chick running around just [__]
blowing people because she enjoys it why
can't she just you know why can't she
have a good time don't you judging her
not you homely hater of a [__] gobbler
I don't know what I'm talking about I'm
just filling up time here Oh as you look
at that 26 minutes in 26 minutes in and
I'm waiting for my lady to wake up I got
a couple of nice gifts a couple of right
there Fred's huh I'm a big fan of buying
your wife like something that she wears
you know because the more [__] did you
buy her that she wears clothes necklace
jewelry ending that [__] the more
that [__] that you buy her the bigger
chance she's going to be wearing it when
she's bitching at you about something
and while you do is you just put your
eyebrows up and then she's rare I read
you just point to whatever your butter
you know stops them right in their
tracks let's say you got some money
Arista what is it then first they look
and what did I put my arm in something
no no right there on your wrist and then
they just looked down then they realized
what you're doing then they just go out
yeah and then you laugh and it's over
you laugh and then it's over right and
you go over you do a couple of Jager
bombs over at your [__] bar you'd be
like what man you're drinking too much
and then you point to their earrings
what is this something on the side I
said oh yeah yeah it's great and then
you get another round telling you all
you [__] who are hiding your booze
in the back of your [__] toilet just
ease off on the booze buy your wife a
couple of things that she's going to be
wear and then you can drink in public
like a man you know Jesus [__] Christ
Jesus you imagine being that big of a
drunk that you're actually like because
that's so [__] cliched you know it's
also brilliant too you know the first
guy who did it because he keeping it
nice and chilled right taking it up the
back oh god what a [__] how unhappy
is that goddamn life you wife's just
sitting there [__] Yammer and at you
and you're going oh my god I don't think
I can get through this you know she
thinks she got some sort of weak bladder
you just keep going in there you know
hmm
taking a little cork out taking a swig
like a [__] pirate
then you got to flush the toilet like
you dropped another deuce oh my god I
guess you get alcoholic you probably eat
better right you just keep eating
veggies all the time so no one will get
wise to the fact you had a little bottle
back there I really don't even know what
I'm talking about right now all I know
is that the Pittsburgh Penguins the knee
breakers they're up two games to none
what a [__] story that's going to be
if they win I'm tell you right now I
don't know what the [__] odds were
but nobody people even in Pittsburgh
didn't even put money down and if they
did they just did it because they loved
their team but nobody at the beginning
of this season
there's no Pittsburgh penguin fan that
said you know what the Penguins are
going to make the [__] Stanley Cup
final they're going to make the finals
we can make the Stanley Cup final and
they're going to go up two games to none
there's not one person not one parami of
panini whatever the [__] in that place
is called with a stick to french fries
and like [__] your breakfast and your
dinner in between those buns right
there's nobody standing down there right
with the giant [__] back roll you
know
Pittsburgh's big on that man people guys
sit down at bars and you just got like
those just softball sized chunk of
[__] large you know just protect like
the kidney airbag right that's it
they're right and you know what that's
not a set
it's a [__] trifecta because once you
got those then you got the [__] butt
crack and that's what you got that's
what you see when you go into those
[__] places and you know Pittsburgh's
not the only place that goes hey you
know we all like Burgers and Fries you
know we all like a sandwich with fries
but it isn't an annoying that you know
you got to hold the sandwich in one hand
and then pick up the fries with the
other would it be great if you could
just have them all between the sandwich
you know what I mean so you can just
shove it down your [__] throat as you
dial in another [__] pizza you know
calling up Domino's or some [__]
they're not the only ones who do that
there's a there's a bunch of [__]
places around the country that
and I'm telling you whenever you go in
in those places I'm telling you you see
the kidney airbags those giant [__]
ham hocks just hanging I mean literally
like I swear to god people in Pittsburgh
I'm telling you like 40% of them you
could literally take an aluminum bat and
just [__] whack them in the brighten
it back fat and it would take them like
probably a good 30 seconds before they
turned around you they felt it in eight
seconds but they got to get all they got
to get the momentum to turn that torso
around and all you got to do is just
stay outside of their meat hooks but I'm
telling you if anybody from Pittsburgh
gets their hands on you it's [__]
over they're going to pull you into that
mass and you're just going to be
claustrophobic like what just kidding
you can they're going to drown you and
their [__] man kids I'm telling you
the ami tourists die a year just
accidentally they go to Pittsburgh for a
[__] pirate game when the most
beautiful stadiums ever right one of
those [__] ham hock Pittsburgh
fatties gets a little too drunk they
lose their [__] equilibrium and they
just fall you know you ever see like
when they go to detonate a building it
doesn't fall right some jerk-off goes to
cut down a tree and it lands on his own
house that's what happens except the
house is a tourist in the trees of fatty
from Pittsburgh all right I don't know
what I'm saying all right that's it
that's the podcast just checking in on
you all right there's some music enjoy
this I don't know what the [__] it's
going to be I don't handle this aspect
of it and then we again you can listen
to the last half-hour be some podcasts
from a year going by from the same
freckle douche that you're listening to
now you have been listening to the
Thursday afternoon Monday morning
podcast just before Friday I hope you
all have a wonderful weekend you [__]
and I hope San Jose one's not the whole
series I just I just need 7 games this
is nothing against Pittsburgh oh it's
just breaking your balls it's just that
this is when like the panic
my sports panic starts settling in like
oh my god the hockey season is over
NBA's over it's just baseball baseball
oh the dog days of [__] baseball the
Red Sox are in first place - I ought to
get into it
oh by the way month of May the cigar
count old freckles I only had one only
have one last three months that I said
I'd up to a month this year I had two in
January two in February two and a half
because one wasn't lit right but I don't
count that one [__] that - two had one
in March one in April one in May so
that's one two three four five six seven
oh you like that that's not bad now
we're not going to discuss my drinking
though because I'll tell you it's off
the [__] jaw
[Music]
all I need and I fall open up for me
there oh you know just coming up there
talking about how things happen as the
year
where it goes otherwise we keep close as
close example walls in heaven
in heaven hey what's going on it's bill
birth it's the Monday morning podcast
that I am doing on Tuesday at 11:20 in
the morning East Coast time
welcome believe that we're gonna be
slipping you know no excuse
actually I do have an excuse it was my
girlfriend's birthday yesterday so I was
being a great boyfriend paying attention
to her and someone had to suffer you
know I mean like a threesome someone
always feels left out matter how much
you try to pay attention my kid men that
had threesome before I couldn't had one
once
I think twice the first time I didn't
realize that it was going down I was so
young and stupid I was actually sitting
there and I was thinking why won't her
roommate leave you know the [__] and it
wasn't until like literally seven years
later I went oh wait a minute she wasn't
leaving cuz [__] and then the other time
I was right there on the table and one
girl was absolutely gorgeous and the
other one uh was not gorgeous let's put
it that way was so not gorgeous that she
eclipses the beauty of the other one you
know so so there you go there you learn
something about me right off the damn
bat okay ah once this is what we're
going to do this week on the podcast you
guys are new to this [__] new to my page
I do want to use every goddamn week and
people ask me questions and I try to
answer them and other than that I babble
I give you information about my life and
and that's it I'm [__] out of it
alright I drank last night okay I was
celebrating connection went to this
goddamn restaurant in New York who went
to Bible and big fan of Mario Batali but
I liked [__] better
was just - it was - what he my palate
was not sophisticated enough but right
I'll take the blame Jesus Christ it was
like regular dishes with [__] you'd
never eat I had beef cheek ravioli yeah
once you [__] take that in for a
minute alright and they had you know
they had like pheasant face [__]
lasagna you know it was always like half
what you had heard of like goose liver
[__] souffle so I don't know it was
it was good but lukla is the [__] that's
the one that I like that's got like
[__] you know regular animals body
parts that you eat mixed in with [__]
rigatoni yeah what the [__] you gonna do
you know yeah you try [__] you know she
wanted to go there [__] took it there
and that's what happened I need two
cupcakes for breakfast what you think
about that it was sitting there leftover
from the party and I said that's a great
way to start my day let me give myself
nine thousand calories of straight sugar
it was unreal it was like I did an eight
ball natural rate the two cupcakes for
twenty minutes I was just sitting there
thinking how [__] great I wasn't I'm
like I'm [__] awesome I could do
anything I want a [__] the greatest
and twenty minutes later when the sugar
started wearing off oh my god I started
pulling the drapes closed playing in
here like I don't know no no don't ever
start your day with [__] tuned to
cupcakes after he had a beef cheek
[__] ravioli
beefcake I was like cheek like the ass
you being cute they're like no they
actually know what I didn't have the
[__] balls to ask him I didn't want
to know I was eating somebody's face
meeting a yak face yeah let me get the
yak paint rat rag goon
all right let's continue with the
continuing story of American Airlines if
you listen to my my podcast last week
these cheap-ass [__] and
American Airlines you know the alligator
arms the [__] food at the first-class
you know I mean they had 20 people in
first-class and they made five omelets
the next thing you know I was eating a
bowl of total over Nebraska actually no
that's not what happened
receive the quick synopsis I said [__]
you and you honeycomb cereal this is
first class I don't get a goddamn
omelette I don't want anything I said
all of that with a little less anger and
no curses so a few seconds later the guy
came back all of a sudden magically he
has an omelette and I'm like where did
you get that and he informs me that the
pilot said he already ate so I could
have his omelette and I was like I don't
want his [__] omelette I want my
omelette all right I don't want to
starving pilot you know passing out up
there seeing bogeys we have poured on
the goddamn yolk whatever you call it
all right so I sent them a letter and
this is the letter that they sent back
to me and I swear to god you know back
in the day if something like this ever
happened and you actually wrote a letter
ug but very least they give you a free
airline ticket and I'm when I say back
in the day I mean like 2005-2006 now
they don't give a [__] they just keep
apologizing profusely this is the
dumbass letter they sent back to me I'm
only going to read your part because
they just keep saying the same thing
over and over again okay I'm gonna get
the hiccups like I have sugar hiccups
I'm stopping down to cupcakes
hang on a second mister monsters hello
yeah I'm going to check out about like
15 minutes of that thank you
Jesus ain't say anything she said handle
I said yeah I'm gonna check out 15
minutes at which point she could have
said okay her old Olay you know but now
she just closes the door alright okay
here's the [__] uh-oh do we got you
this bill this is a letter that American
Airlines sent me okay dear mr. burr
thank you for contacting American
Airlines it's our privilege to respond
to your message okay first of all right
there they already pissed me off okay
don't don't start with off with your
[__] stock line like your Jackie
Gleason you know thank you for writing
us in a way we go you know a little
shoving off the Buffalo okay I'm very
sorry to hear of your disappointment
with us and regret that you did not
receive your preferred entree when you
traveled with us in the first-class
cabin see how soulless this is because
we want your travel experience or
improving premium cabins to be truly
something special we do our best to
cater our entree selections so that we
can serve each customer the entree they
prefer this is the part which is just
complete [__] okay they want to make
sure that they serve the entree that I
prefer you know you can do that bringing
up [__] eggs on the flight this is
what they write to do so we determined
which entrees are selected most often it
often and provision accordingly it's so
there's such [__] [__] I mean and
then they watch Jurassic Park when Jeff
Goldblum did his little rant about chaos
theory because you take ten flights or a
hundred flights and you figure out you
know seven people want the omelet and in
you know nine people want something else
it's such [__] first of all nobody
wants the [__] cereal
someone wants cereal at first class okay
you [__] drop fifteen hundred dollars
or whatever the hell is $850 on ticket
you want something of substance
I'm sick of bitching about this all I
know is in the end of it I end up flying
[__] a middle seat to [__] Dallas
and all I got was a 150 dollar voucher
which will pay for 1/3 they didn't give
me anything mister peres we are not
unmindful of the inconvenience of you
well how the [__] would you be on
mindful I wrote you a goddamn letter
it's hard as we are trying to deliver on
respecting your time by operating our
flights is scheduled it just wasn't
possible this time again we apologize
for the disruption of your travel plans
we're not giving you [__] please fly
with us again soon we'll do our best to
get you to your destination as planned
really you're going to do your best
that's what you can give me American
Airlines well gee you know we're going
to try that's a comforting attitude to
have when they're going to be flying a
[__] at 36,000 feet off the goddamn
ground although I sound like a [__] this
week so that's basically it that's
that's the the next level that they've
taken a trip where it used to be like
okay we [__] you over and the stewardess
gives you a [__] you know that was
1975 in the 80s it was you know we'll
give you a free ticket and a skinny
Michael J Fox tie number those things
you know when you have a little spiked
out mullet and that lasted for good 20
years and somewhere in the last four or
five years it became we're going to [__]
you over a red bag go [__] yourself
we didn't let that go [__] yourself it
was 299 other people on the plane it
didn't some fitting complaint what do
you do take the train then take you nine
days to get to New York go [__] yourself
you know you're coming back it's just
eggs
get over yourself you know what they got
me over god damn barrel sons of [__]
what am I gonna do fly a TA you know
Nina [__] I don't know what in a
goddamn chicken so I'm actually I think
a TA recently went out of business give
a flying airline and then you know you
look at you know it's kind of weird
flight you know there was a crack in the
inner window actually I happen to be on
a TA with one of the windows you know
they got like to dig up
pane of glass they got the one on the
outside the outside of the plane and
then they have the one on the inside the
extra level one and that one was cracked
and I believe there's a little bit of
water in there and I said to the to the
stewardess I was like woman there's a
[__] crack in the goddamn window over
here I'm afraid I'm gonna get sucked out
once we get above 6000 feet she sits
like no so Kara stole another glass you
know so I didn't feel bad when they went
out of business now I kind of felt bad
because now there's no there's no other
option I guess that's my another option
do I sit there and I take it on American
Airlines when they go go [__] yourself
all right we're going to give you a bran
muffin I hope you brought some water or
I fly another airline when their inner
window is cracked but no one picks it's
a concern
tanner winters crack well that it that's
why we got to open all right this is
this podcast is just across the [__]
let's get to some podcast questions that
I didn't even I didn't have the time to
[__] look at this week actually
that's not true
I want to look at them and somebody I
don't know what's going on with my
myspace page I don't know if anybody
else has had this problem but I am not
that evil really and anybody for about a
year you know every couple of days
they'll get about 45 requests I'll
accept them and and a day later I have
47 people taken off my page and it's
like really where all those people
spammers I don't know what's going on so
I'm having somebody look at my account
the only question I can remember I can't
even remember it was something about
[__] you know what movies do I find
scary well you know what if you turn my
flight on American Airlines into a movie
I would have found that [__] scary
what will we do I find scary anything
that involves a crazy woman I think the
scariest movies when I first got cable
in the early eighties when I had type
change in the Pony high-tops that just
met the bottom of my jeans and no one
complained
because somehow you could get away with
that back time I remember the first
Friday the 13th when Jason came up out
of the lake that scared the [__] out of
me
and there was another one here here's
one for you okay I got a podcast
question for you guys there was a movie
I saw late night cable and I can't
remember what the [__] it was it's
somehow there was somebody skating
across the pond in slow motion with an
axe and I believe for some reasons the
[Music]
the monster I'm picturing is from that I
know this isn't it but it's a good
picture my mind is uh what does that
monster book where the wild things are
remember what those monsters look like
in my memory that's what the months to
look like skating across the [__] lake
and I know it isn't that but I know
somebody what are you one of my 14
listeners out there has to be a [__]
[__] for a film whatever the [__] would
he call someone's really in the horror
films a geek yeah exactly
a horror film [__] geek it was that
one and it was another one I was just
thinking of and I just sat up and I
can't remember it I'm getting at that
[__] age I really just moved my brain
a little bit the thought just went away
wait a second what the [__] was I just
thinking
let me lay back down let me see it'll
come back to me they'll talk in a bucket
we got to go back in time here I was
talking okay the lake the wild things
are see just how my brain works the
worst linear once I go past the moment I
can't go back like a [__] traffic jam
what the [__] was I trying to think of
ah [__] I don't know oh I got it BAM
there we go
Dark Knight of the Scarecrow I like the
old horror movies okay this is what you
know what I don't like about new horror
movies did they with that CGI [__] they
they can do so much insane stuff with
computers that they forgot how to build
suspense the old ones they used they
used to build it up they used to build
up the moment where the monster was
going to jump out at you because they
had to because it was just a guy in a
rubber [__] suit you know what I mean
but now that they could they can you
know they can make it look like
Godzilla's stepping on New York they
forgot how to build suspense that's what
I don't like about [__] horror movies
now and that's uh I think Japanese I
don't know everybody over in Asia seems
to know how to [__] do that but
nobody over here does even like the
lifelike thrillers whatever the [__]
it whatever a goddamn thriller is might
take that that movie a perfect storm
they had that goddamn big wave that's
all they showed in the trailer so
everybody goes out to run out and see it
and then they don't develop any of the
goddamn characters to the point that I
don't give a [__] about anybody in the
movie so by the buddy in the movie I'm
actually praying for the wave I can't
wait for them to kill George Clooney and
Mark Wahlberg and all those other guys
because I don't give a [__] about their
characters because they haven't done
anything to make me give a [__] they
just had a couple people speak in Boston
accent and you stick them on a tugboat
and I'm supposed to give a [__] that
they're going to die trying to get lop
stuff I'm just in a bad mood I'm in a
bad [__] mood today I'll let you know
what it is it's a guy and don't ever
start your day with two [__] cupcakes
it seems like such a great you know such
a great idea you know like oh I'm eight
years old this is what you'd want to do
but your parents never let you you know
and now I'm 39 and fifty-one weeks
and finally the dream that I thought was
going to happen you know oh it could
happen and it doesn't play out like oh
my god how did I forget this [__] I know
I forgot it because I have [__] two
cupcakes with the sugar in my brain I
actually had a crazy week how crazy was
it bill um I flew into New York on
Wednesday I did Opie and Anthony thing
opening Anthony Opie and Anthony show
Thursday morning then I did my show at
Caroline's in New York Thursday night I
got up Friday morning got on a plane
flew back to LA I did the guys Choice
Awards on Spike TV met all these famous
people they were all cool I had a great
time I met Nikki sick I was way more
thrilled and the after-party was at the
[__] Playboy Mansion and I know what
you're thinking oh my god Playboy's
[__] mentioned that must have been
unbelievable I quickly realized when I
got there there's two kinds of parties
at the Playboy Mansion there's B you're
famous and you can come by Wednesday
afternoon and actually meet the broads
that are in the magazine and then
there's the one that I want to wear it's
like yeah why don't you guys all just
stand on my in my backyard
I literally thought Ashok's of mansion
right was gonna be like me and eight
other people and just you know for
Playboy Bunnies each just rubbing on my
chest came here big boy I heard you're
comedian now they just had they they had
the it was definitely the B team of
Playboy bunny
you know they had little bunny suits on
in the rabbit ear so let me tell you
something they were they were grade-a
hooter girls and he could tell there was
three of them who were clearly being
paid to frolic in the pool and any girl
with bunny ears had like nine guys
around her was a [__] sausage fest
and this is the funny thing nobody was
hitting on him they were standing there
with their [__] cameras out taking
pictures like like they were at
Disneyland and they ran into Donald Duck
or something
it was pathetic and you know Hugh Hefner
was roped off with his three [__]
girlfriends 83 years old man's guiding
musician that was the only thing I
wanted to do I just want to go in there
and shake his hand and then immediately
stick my hand in Bleach to get the
unbelievable smell of 50 years of [__]
off of my hand and then fly back but he
was busy I understand he had to meet
famous [__] people so but still was
filled with [__] and then I flew back
the next day six in the [__] morning
I landed in New York at about 4:30 I got
my bag I went over Caroline's and I did
three [__] shows you know and then I
went out drinking afterwards and that's
the kind of thing that leads you to be
in a country mood on a Tuesday morning
you know I did all of that and then I
ate two cupcakes all right so don't even
question my [__] move all right so um
so there you go that was my week huh
what - a party - Playboy Mansion I could
stand up on my first award show when is
it going to be at you ask why I'll tell
you it's going to be on June 22nd and I
had a great time doing the set even
though most of the crowd was at a crowd
you know good-looking people hot chicks
texting each other oh my god look at one
this is going to be over if I stick a
lot I want to blow Jeremy Piven gonna be
on June 22nd and this week coming up
this week I'm going to be at a good
night's comedy club in Raleigh North
Carolina you can go to billboard calm
and get all the [__] informations and
later on this month I'm going to be the
punchline in Atlanta Hotlanta is the
brother to call it and I think that date
is June 19th or something like that I
don't [__] know I can't get on this
hotel Internet and I have to check out
in 19 [__] minutes so I got to go
apologize for the podcast being a day
late and forgive my country myths on
this podcast I'm going to blame it on
the sugar from the two cupcakes
what a [__]
half a [__] huh starts the day with two
cupcakes so they call me Billy -
cupcakes Billy cupcake alright you guys
have a good week please keep the podcast
questions comments are about this week
man I don't know what's going on with my
[__] page but please keep them coming
and let people know about my podcast and
thanks everybody came out to my shows a
night in Philadelphia Chicago and in New
York City all right you guys all have a
good week I'll talk to you later
[Music]
no way
let's go
[Music]
yeah
like your mind
I was prepping this hoodie one day
everybody was about to pop me back into
the system
everybody's looking for that little
fella
[Music]
necklace load
what happened without
[Music]
when I sleep
you
[Music]